horror cinema is booming right now and
the scares don't seem to be slowing down
at all in 2020 the next decade of cinema
scares will kick off in a big way
with everything from long awaited
sequels to daring reboots to new takes
on some classic ghost stories in 2004
two years after the ring launched a wave
of American interest in Japanese horror
cinema
we got The Grudge this english-language
remake of the 2002 Japanese Scarefest
Juwan brought stateside audiences a look
at the curses and hauntings that form in
places where angry violent deaths have
occurred The Grudge got two sequels in
2006 and 2009 but the Jew on franchise
has continued in Japan with nine films
and Counting now the American remake
franchise is getting its own reboot
grudge will serve to reset the American
version of the franchise with a new
story of a vengeful spirit haunting a
house where past violence took place and
formed a curse the film features an
impressive cast led by Andrea
Riseborough Demian Bichir and Jacki
Weaver the film was originally set to be
released in June of 2019 but was later
pushed back to January 3rd 2020 Henry
James's novella the turn of the screw is
one of the most popular and influential
ghost stories ever written and it's been
adapted for the screen numerous times in
2020 the classic tale will get a new
modern take with the turning this
version of the story will be set in
modern Maine but will still tell the
story of a governess tasked with caring
for two young children after the deaths
of their parents as she settles in for
the job she begins to suspect the
mysterious estate where the family is
living maybe harboring a number of dark
secrets and may in fact be haunted the
film is worth getting excited about for
any number of reasons its Floria sages
Mondays second feature film after The
Runaways and it'll be fascinating to see
how she adapts her visual style honed in
music videos and episodes of prestige TV
to this ghost story setting the cast is
also stacked with talent thanks to the
presence of McKenzie Davis Finn wolfhard
and Brooklyn Prince in the story is
iconic the turning will hit theaters
January 24th 2020 in 2014 Universal
Pictures tried to revamp its universe of
classic movie monsters with the prequel
story Dracula untold it didn't quite
land but in 2000
17 they tried again with an even more
ambitious effort an attempt to launch an
interconnected dark universe with the
money that film also didn't work out so
now it seems the studio is refocusing
its intentions with more standalone
efforts The Invisible Man is the first
of these and it'll be directed by Leigh
Whannell the man responsible for giving
a saw insidious and upgrade the
Invisible Man is scheduled to hit the
screen on march 13th 2020 equai 'it was
one of the most successful and acclaimed
genre films of 2018 and it didn't take
long for talks of a sequel to emerge
after it hit big with audiences John
Krasinski will return to both write and
direct the second installment in the
franchise while his wife Emily Blunt
will also return to star the film's full
plot is still unknown but we do know it
will follow the surviving members of the
Abbott family now led by blunts Evelyn
as they continue to try to survive
together after learning a trick to
defeat the creatures at the end of the
first film will a third installment
follow we'll have to wait and see a
quiet place to sneaks into theaters
March 20th 2020 in May of 2019 the
internet was both delighted and a little
confused by reports that legendary
comedian Chris Rock would be venturing
into horror territory with a new
spin-off film set in the saw universe
the 9th saw film working from a story
developed by rock is in development and
will hit theaters in the spring of 2020
Biggs and Van der beek around the set
chocolate well I don't see where the
stars pieces we still don't know much
about the film's plot but we do know
that rock is also set to star as a
detective investigating a killer who
likes to build elaborate puzzles for his
victims in that samuel l.jackson has
added even more star power to the cast
after signing on to play the father of
rocks character the still untitled ninth
saw film hits theaters May 15th 2020 in
1992 a new horror legend was born with
Candyman a story about a hook-handed
killer who lived on as a vengeful
murderous urban legend long after he was
the victim of a lynch mob in the 19th
century
Candyman is a modern horror masterpiece
that spawned two sequels and lives on
through a devoted fanbase eager to
analyze every piece of this often
deceptively deep film
Bosh's and we shall never be separated
again candy mans ongoing reputation as
one of the best horror films of the
1990s was enough to draw attention from
Jordan Peele who's now helping bring a
spiritual sequel to the original film to
the big screen
Candyman 2020 will be directed by Nia de
Costa from a script by Pele in his
monkey paw productions partner Wynne
Rosenfeld the still mysterious Candy Man
arrives on the big screen June 12 2020
in 2013 a relatively small-scale horror
film about a pair of paranormal
investigators blew up at the box office
that film was the conjuring and in just
six years it spawned one direct sequel
and five spin-off films the conjuring
universe has become a horrid juggernaut
for the 2010s and in 2020 the third film
in the main series will finally arrive
on the big screen not much is known yet
about the plot of the conjuring 3 which
will feature the return of Patrick
Wilson and Vera Farmiga as the war ends
and will be directed by Michael shaves
who helmed the spin-off the curse of La
Llorona we also know that it will veer
away from the haunted house format
offered in the first two films the
conjuring 3 will be terrifying audiences
on September 11th 2020 in 2018 director
David Gordon Green brought star Jamie
Lee Curtis back to the Halloween
franchise with a new film that ignored
all previous sequels setting the stage
for a showdown between Laurie Strode and
Michael Myers that in this universe had
been for decades in the making
that film simply titled Halloween was
one of the year's biggest horror hits
and though it could have closed the book
on the franchise talk of a sequel began
to surface in July of 2019 we found out
that we'd be getting not just one but
two sequels in the span of two years the
first of those Halloween kills will
arrive in 2020 Green will return to
direct and co-write the film with Danny
McBride while Curtis will also return as
Laurie Strode with Judy Greer and Andy
matichek returning as Laurie's daughter
and granddaughter respectively given how
the past film set up a legacy of strong
women in the strode family it'll be very
intriguing to see how the next film
expands on this new version of the
mythology Halloween kills arrives
October 16 2020 it will be followed by
the final film in the trilogy Halloween
ends on October
fifteen 2021 check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite scary movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one